mental health stuff are you open about
I'm open about everything
I'm ready rocking within that guy's
earns no no no go zones you got your
perspective Oh Gary you have this
incredible gift when you open your mouth
everyone listens I don't know if it's
because there's a lot of swearing but
you have that gift and you can turn the
world around in a certain way how you're
gonna use that I know you do it for
business but how else you know I think I
have a lot of ambitions with how else
you know over the last five years
especially in really the last three as
my awareness and and the internet fame
has grown it's been very clear to me
that I touch on subjects whether it's
parenting whether it's happiness you
know my great passion is to redefine
what success looks like and turn it from
something that is around money and make
it around you know happiness and and
just feeling light and so you know even
though that's a very daunting question I
think about it the same way that I've
built all my businesses which is one day
at a time
one step at a time one piece that we one
piece of content at a time want to
interview at a time one talk at a time
execution and patience I think I think
one of the things that I feel very
confident about is I think there's a lot
of us in the world people that are
watching you I people behind the cameras
right now that have great ambition to
leave a good impact to do good to spread
happiness but I find a lot of people are
impatient you know to make a huge impact
on happiness in the world
that's boiling the ocean that shouldn't
happen overnight that shouldn't happen
in three seasons that should be in
perpetuity and so patience
so what do you think underneath like
I've been watching a lot of your content
and you're such a great person to speak
to about business but I want to know
more about Gary be behind the business
and it feels like have you taken a turn
more towards helping individuals more so
than even the business side of things at
some level you know it three four years
ago I was very passionate about putting
out these really tactical business
advices that I thought really could help
people seize the opportunity that the
Internet is and I kept trying to figure
out why they weren't doing things why
weren't they executing why weren't they
putting out content and it led me to a
path of like wait a minute there's a
level of confidence and a level of not
being insecure and a level of dealing
with judgment that I have which has led
me to far more strategic conversations
around mindset and so yes I think as
I've kept digging down the well you know
the reality is is that so much of my
business advice is predicated on
foundational mental strength so you're
not gonna put yourself out there if
you're worried about a comment in the
comment section or what your mom is
gonna think and so yeah I think over the
last three or four years the evolution
of listening to why people weren't doing
things that were very clear and working
has led me down a more mental path when
you say to me I think a lot of this is
exercise right by saying stop worrying
about people's opinions are you gonna
live your life based on somebody else's
opinion don't worry and think back to
the way you were parented your
insecurity comes from some of the
missteps of your parents but don't over
judge them it is what it is it's on you
accountability to get there I think it's
practice it's just practice you know
it's just practice it's building a
muscle wake up every day get a bad
comment and and this is why I'm so
prolific in my daily
and I just want to keep talking about it
and hoping that it you know to your
point and thank you for saying it I was
born with a gift that makes people pay
attention so if i've got them in i'm
just gonna pound them there's not a
whole lot of different things I'm gonna
say over the next 70 years there isn't
much else to be said there's very clear
found a foundational aspects of this so
I think it's practice and I think the
813 time that I say it is the day some
woman in Hunter Valley says you know
what today's the day I'm gonna jump and
she makes a video and she's scared to do
it and there's some tough comments and
it's a little bit easier because she's
practiced building up the courage it's
no different than the kid who wants to
learn how to swim or kissing a girl or
riding a bike you're building yourself
up right
you're like today's the day today's the
day you know and you put your toe in the
water and and you said today was gonna
be day and you didn't do it and you went
home and the next day you go to the pool
it's a it's it's practice I mean modern
schools across the globe are not built
for the realities of 2020 so it doesn't
mean you need to be disrespectful it
doesn't mean that you just need to quit
please recognize if you're not a great
scholar that a lot of hard work is in
front of you but yes III think that if
you're a parent right now and watching
this most parents struggle with their
children not doing well in school today
because they worry about the judgment of
other parents which is really
unfortunate I look into the camera and I
plead to parents of today please don't
pair your children based on other
parents opinions you know it's it's it's
a it's very sad to think that parents
are willing to force their kids to do
things that they deeply know their kids
are not about because they're worried
about what the neighbors gonna say for
the kids that are watching I say look
you know you need to be self-aware you
know I know school can be a drag please
recognize if you don't do it that you're
going
have to work hard and forever and so you
know cuz you'll be starting our lower
point you know that diploma is not going
to get you in the door so you're gonna
start at the dirt I think there's a lot
of entitlement from bad students then a
guy I'm a bad student but I'm gonna be
an entrepreneur being Austin or is
ridiculously hard and so I highly
recommend a lot of self-awareness both
on the parent and the kid level gets
deployed you just gotta try it and
hustling yep is that the key that is the
key now look I'm sure there's a lot of
kids or grown-ups who actually feel the
way I did which was I knew but I didn't
really know you know it felt natural it
felt like I had it it seemed that every
time I put my foot in the water a
lemonade stand selling some baseball
cards trying to shovel snow that I did
well but until you do something you
don't fully know I think the key right
now is to make sure you're not doing it
because it's cool because everybody else
is doing it everybody wants to start a
business
everybody's got a side hustle
everybody's got an app idea that is a
modern day phenomenon that is a reaction
to the Internet itself it's appropriate
but before you tell me you're gonna
build the next Facebook or uber before
you're gonna make a million bucks why
not make a hundred bucks why not
actually put your foot in front of you
and so you don't necessarily know but if
you love it if you love it if it just
gets you going the idea of buying and
selling something or starting something
or building a community
you must scratch that itch because
regret is probably the thing that I fear
the most and I see to me the saddest
thing in the world is an 80 or 90 year
old that I come across that is deeply
grounded and regret because it feels
like you know it feels like you can't do
anything about it anymore and and a lot
of people have it
no cuz it's too early I'm sure I will -
we're all human
but it's too early there the great thing
about being 43 especially the way that I
contextualize time I don't even feel
like I've lived half my life yet and so
it's tough for me to regret but actually
that's not fair
I would actually tell you it doesn't you
know it's funny it doesn't come across
as regret but there's definitely a golly
gee shucks I wish I had a little more
fun in my teenager 20 or in my teenage
years or 20s you know when I talk about
how hard I worked in my 20s only the
five or six people that were closest to
me really actually know how true it is
how extreme it is I really really really
didn't take any vacation time or
weekends in my 20s and I do have a level
of regret of that a couple of weekends
with the boys a couple of trips couldn't
it could have done me some good now I
know you come from amazing parents and
amazing background and and you talk a
lot about children not having those same
what it wasn't about your parents that
we could pass on to other parents my
parents had two extremes my mom was
deeply optimistic and build self
confidence in me and over loved me and
my dad was deeply pessimistic very much
around work ethic and and and saw the
world differently and in those extreme
contradictions I think I became the
Enigma or anomaly that I am now there's
also some DNA in that meaning a lot of
people on both my parents you know my
parents even joke like you've really
made us out to be these super parents
and it's because I'm focused on seeing
the good so that's how I see it believe
that I do believe that but I do think it
was encouraged I do think that if my dad
and mom switched and I grew up with a
parent that was deeply pessimistic from
1 to 14 that some of that optimism would
have gone from 8 to a 7 versus what I
think with my mom and 8 to a 10 so I do
think you know this has been figured out
long before I came along this nature
nurture environment is very real and so
yes I think there are things deeply
dna'd wise about me but I do think the
way I was nurtured the environment I
grew up in and the parenting I had had
an impact as well much like I look at my
sisters only three and a half years
younger than me
right for me by the way I know all the
noises going on I see everybody behind
camera I love this so if you're watching
at home I love the chaos so my sister's
only three and a half years younger than
me and she's wired to be pessimistic and
I think she's a three who got parented
and had an older brother that moved her
to a six again if she was raised by my
grandmother you know who was very
pessimistic she might have been a three
that became a one and so that's how I
see it
where do you see yourself 0 to 10 on the
head
eleven everyday everyday really I'm
driven by gratitude I'm incapable of
being upset around things that don't
matter and everything besides the health
of nine people doesn't matter when a
parent of mine passes away that 11 will
become a zero for a day a month a year I
don't know I haven't crossed that bridge
but I have put myself in a very
interesting box mentally which is my
perspective is binary it is black and
white
either the nine or ten or eleven people
I love the most or healthy and woke up
this morning and didn't die and thus I'm
fully happy or not
and losing an account or having people
write something bad about me or having a
PR headache or something didn't work out
the way I wanted or somebody stabbed me
in the back or it's just it resonates
for a second maybe it gets up I mean
extremely difficult things that I that I
noticed contemporaries struggle with
carry three minutes of anxiousness with
me sixty five seconds of inconvenience
mate if it's traumatic maybe a couple of
hours before it translates into this
really doesn't matter what you said
yourself at the time or do you practice
developed over time I probably have
spent the last 15 years of my life
making pretend that my mom died yeah
yeah I do a lot of things where
something great happens or something bad
happens and I make pretend and then the
phone rang and my mom died so how would
I feel what I feel like this huge trophy
I just got meant anything no would I
feel like this terrible thing that
happened in business today was terrible
no so yeah I've been practicing for a
very long time and Mexico way to look at
things yeah yeah it really works for me
I can see how it would work but it's not
something anyone would think of yet
something I've been thinking about
putting out more in the world like
really just think about it like just
really wake up and go to sleep every
night and make
and the singular person you love the
most just died in a horrific accident I
know it you know I get it I get it but
but look I want to be very empathetic
people are watching this we all know the
majority of the world deals with issues
they watching a man who just said he's
an 11 on the 1 to 10 happiness scale
that can come across very insincere and
the follow-up to why I'm there is an
extreme different kind of thought
process that isn't talked about in
contemporary times that I would like to
argue is worth a debate whether it works
for others or not I don't know but it is
what I do it is what I do and if seeing
you as being so successful they want to
know how your brain tips so maybe these
little things the things we haven't
thought about but should be thinking
about and if they look at my success as
an ability to walk around very light
versus the money I've made or the
followers I have then the hack that I
just gave is even more powerful and I
would argue that a lot of my business
success comes from the fact that I have
not had to take a lot of hours ever in
25 professional years to sit and worry
about something that's happening outside
the business I'm giving it my all
carefree and that's nice a flashing back
school so that what was the tricky thing
that made you get the D's and F's was it
you just let sick ADHD was probably
probably I don't know I wasn't diagnosed
with the either but it was a different
time in the 80s it was deep self
awareness that everything that was going
on in that classroom was completely
irrelevant to what I was going to be it
was either a mix of unbelievable
audacity or incredible self awareness at
such a young age and probably a little
bit of both and I just remember being in
fourth grade I remember vividly sitting
in mr. mole nars
science class saying I'm gonna win
anyway I don't care about Saturn
I love that I don't care how I get to
the teacher no I was so you know
something I think a lot about actually
is how bad of a student I was and how
disruptive in class I was because I was
always a little bit of a showman in
hindsight very much a class clown but
but unbelievably liked by my teachers
for somebody who was disruptive because
I think what I the reason I wouldn't say
that was it was very uncomfortable for
me to be disrespectful so I would play
you know right yeah I would understand
where I could get away with things that
was worse you know that would seem like
light-hearted or it sounds like you can
completely raid people's a hundred
percent yeah
and that it must be a massive skill in
it is the skill it is the skill of life
yes if I could wish anybody anything
besides health it would be emotional
intelligence where do you see yourself
20 30 years time you know don't think in
those kind of ways I you know my
intuition is a far more complete
stronger thoughtful version of Who I am
today with probably a lot more awareness
you know I'm I intuitively have this
deep feeling that everybody on earth is
gonna know who I am
I really do I really do
so you know probably in a very
interesting place like you've got the
stage ready to go what if you could say
something to the world
and raise their happiness what do you
think the key things I think giving more
than you take is an incredible way to
get I think that I think that karma is
practical I think that doing the right
thing and being the bigger person in
every situation is always right I think
that happiness is remarkably quiet and
negativity is extremely loud and so do
not allow that to confuse you of how
great things are I think those things
stand out to me of loud and and quiet
you know I think a lot of people right
now you know social media exposes us it
doesn't change us and what in my true
belief that negativity is always louder
than positivity louder not truer what
you're seeing right now is a lot of
people arguing and complaining and
spitting poison on social yet the 99%
that are silent are actually in a good
place and back to your point if via the
world stage the reason I would want to
push that is I would like to create a
call of arms of if you're in a good
place to share like I'm proud that this
morning when I was brushing my teeth in
Sydney I literally looked at my phone it
is my framework to think that way and I
tweeted a blue heart a blue heart emoji
why blue I don't know not necessarily my
favorite color I just saw like but but
actually actually I do know
subconsciously I think somebody might
have an attachment to a blue heart and
when they just see it that might like if
16 people are affected by that in a
positive way and so I think we need a
lot more of that why do we only tweet
when we complain about an airline how
about when you had a lovely flight why
can't we tweet that we had an incredible
stewardess why don't we do that and I
think and I think we need to make
positivity louder as a collective
tell me do you have any kind of
spirituality or faith behind what you do
not really you know it's interesting my
my family grew up in the Soviet Union
and what a lot of people don't know
about communism is that religion is
outlawed all religion is outlawed by
communism so starting at my
great-grandfather level the majority of
my family never really practice the
faith of being Jewish so we are not
deeply religious I don't really even
know you know there is no spiritual
guide or scriptures or books I've read
I'm just deeply intuitive around my
humanity and kindness and that's what I
follow you know it's funny I have always
and still feel that if you ask me that
question I would say I do but but I
don't really think of it much more past
that and I don't know if I'm checking
the box because it's a thing to say I I
will say that I'm unbelievably cynical
to religion in the fact that I think a
lot of it underlining creates lines in
the sand to hate others so I think the
manifestation of modern man and woman of
religion is something that should be
questioned I think there's a you know
it's my great fear right now with the
rise of nationalism around the world
anything that says we're Americans and
screw everybody else we're Australians
and screw everybody else we're women and
screw everybody else we're you know you
know Jews or Muslims or Christians and
scrub anything that does anything that
says I don't like another fellow human
is deeply uncomfortable to me and that
comes in the form of many different
tribes whether religion or country or
gender yeah so I struggle with that
yeah president I would feel that if I
was born in America which is a
requirement to be present in the United
States that I would run for president of
the United States probably now for that
matter I think I would win I think I I
think I would win I think what what
gives me a shot is that socially and
humanity wise I have a lot of liberal
characteristics however business wise
and merit wise I have a lot of
conservative and I'm able to carry those
two and I think in America right now
unfortunately we're pushing in opposite
directions I think you could be a winner
and a sweetheart and and that that's
what I'm pushing for thank you
could be long-winded but not
overthinking so if you had three people
over for a barbecue who would you love
to have them dead or alive but Randy the
Macho Man Savage and my two
grandfather's that I never got to know
what's your kryptonite uh that's a
really good question um an interesting
what is my kryptonite yeah which is rare
but it's a great question uh the health
of my family definitely the health of my
family what do you want your children to
say about you as a dad that he showed us
how to live he didn't tell us no but
they're very aware of their father
swears a lot they would be awfully well
off I always know when I'm on TV
and lastly wage with heavy place within
my own head I want to be in your head
just a day then my you know it's funny
you just asked that question
and the first things I saw was head
against an airplane in the shower
washing my hair I'm desperate to figure
out how to over communicate whatever
infrastructure I have around my mindset
because
I'm sure for everybody listening that
quick answer is an awfully good answer
for the human race not as many as I'd
like and that is and there's a level of
guilt and that's that I don't drives
this enormous need to communicate at
scale around this issue that's why we
love what you're doing cuz everyone's
just soaking it up thank you my very
last question please
I know you're sports fan yes have you
gonna fill a FL team yet I do not have a
footy team oh thank you
they're on top of the letter very pretty
and this is a very cool cat
it is a cool cat and this is fantastic
all right guys I'm sure a lot of people
gonna be super upset and start hitting
me up on social but I'm in so good thank
you
Cheers thank you everybody it's a nice
house great hat wave from so long but
too long on top of the letter are they
you